the third rise in fuel prices within two
weeks is making it even more difficult
for many Zimbabweans to survive soaring
inflation higher food prices and rising
unemployment is making things even worse
which is why the opposition movement for
Democratic Change is planning to protest
on Friday in the capital her re going to
be a way of sending a clear message
that's enough is enough we cannot
continue to fold our hands when our
mothers are suffering we cannot continue
to fold away ends when you don't get
adequate food in our place we cannot
continue before the end when we don't
have fuel in our city stations we can
mention a number of things give up $4
yen's when there are no jobs in the
bubble the protest organizers say the
demonstration will be peaceful but the
police are expecting violence a year ago
soldiers shot and killed protesters
disputing election results most of all
beings were killed in January for
demonstrating against rising fuel prices
government calls on all progressive
Zimbabwe's to desist from being used by
negative forces to disturb belies their
own country is this will only prolong
the hardships which government is
tirelessly working to address in a more
sustainable manner civil society
organizations say they are concerned
about increasing human rights abuses
before Friday's protests we note with
regret that six people so far were
abducted by suspected state agents in
the evening of 13 and 14 August 2019 and
they've been severely tortured and left
for dead one of the victims at the
harmful caustic liquid poured on his
body during the torture the men accused
the victims of being involved in
organizing the August 16 demonstrations
officials from the rulings on EPF denied
the allegations
opposition parties blamed president MS
Managua and the zanu-pf government for
what they say is the worst economic
crisis in a decade President Ma Simon
and Gaga says fixing the economy will
take time and that zimbabwean some need
to be patient but that's something
mainly have little of these days
opposition leaders say Friday's protests
were the first of many they are planning
more demonstrations in several cities
and towns across the country next week
the success of those planned protests
would largely depend on what happens on
Friday in the Capitol Hart Matassa al
Jazeera